the big tax reform fight happening right
now in the Senate and one issue that
kind of popped up and is a little bit
surprising is the issue of further
increasing the child tax credit and it's
actually being championed by one senator
in particular Republican Marco Rubio and
he's found himself kind of crossways
with the white house in some
conservatives as a result thinner Rubio
thanks so much for joining us tonight
exciting times with the tax reform on
the horizon finally we're moving forward
to a real debate
I talked to Mitch McConnell earlier
tonight and he thinks he's gonna be able
to get this done he's very optimistic
tonight The Wall Street Journal has an
editorial titled the Rubio Schumer
amendment Florida Republican tries to
blow up the Senate tax reform what are
you up to you got to blow up the Senate
tax if they're wrong about it let me
tell you what it is very simple it's a
child tax credit and it's and it's
designed to help working people who are
the people that would benefit from this
firefighters members of the Armed
Services teachers construction workers
well they get a child time so what it is
is it a lot of people because they make
$40,000 a year okay they don't get to
fully benefit from the child tax credit
because they don't have a lot of pay
income tax liability but they pay
payroll tax there they're working people
in this country that have been ignored
and forgotten they're the people that
elected President Trump because they've
been not just ignored but disrespected
and all this says is you're gonna get to
keep more of your own money that's what
the amendment does they actually say
it's a disincentive to work that's
ridiculous you can't even get the tax
credit if you're not working so this is
people making between 20 and 50 or
$60,000 would benefit greatly and by the
way if you look at the states that would
benefit the most I think it's 18 of the
top 20 states voted for the president in
the 2016 election why because working
people raising children are the people
that voted to elect the president with a
very clear message that they sent us
here to fight for them not for the money
to interest a control I think president
initially wanted 15 then it went to 20
as the corporate tax code but now under
your plan it would
2:22 on the corporate side a 22%
corporate tax rate it's 13 points lower
than what it is now 20 difference
between 2022 it would still make us
third among the g7 nations that would
still put us below that in the global
average there is no difference in growth
between 20 and 22 especially when you
factor in no matter yes they do matter
but not in but not not in terms of
growth you're not gonna see any less
growth at 22 than you would at 20 it
still puts us lower than the world it's
still ranked the tsardom on the g7 and
by the way there's another way to pay
for it
I'm open to a hundred billion dollars or
so about 80 billion dollars down a
hundred billion Wow well here's why
because we want a lot of it to inflation
but it's not our money it's not the
government's money it's the working
people's money these are welders these
are plants they're getting a rebate for
children having children what about
people who don't have kids who oh I'm
not making money what about them well
big break but they also don't have the
expense of raising children what we're
saying here is you are raising children
if you make $50,000 a year and you're
raising three kids that money doesn't go
nearly as far as if you're not writing
taxes either from the most part they're
not really they don't have much of a tax
liability but they still get they still
qualify for all sorts of deals where you
will you be willing to blow the deal up
if they don't go to 20 I don't want to
blow up a deal because if there is no
tax reform there is no vehicle by which
we confess this now and it already does
go up to $2,000 yeah I have never talked
about conditioning anything I am saying
this makes our tax reform
no more pro-worker which is where we
need to be as a country speaking of
workers you want to do a doc a deal
before the end of the year yeah well you
would like to if possible do you think
Donald Trump was elected to do a daca
amnesty before something like Obamacare
repeal well I think we tried to do
Obamacare repeal as you saw it failed
unfortunately because we couldn't get
our conference together here's what I've
said there's there's a difference
between daca and the DREAM Act if what
they want to do and the president's
expressed an openness to this is to do
something like daca but constitutionally
that's temporary and acts as a bridge
towards something more permanent that's
one thing if what they want is to make a
permanent change to immigration policy
it must be accompanied by permanent
changes to security McConnell said
open to ending chain migration Eve Arif
I mostly what Tom cotton and Purdue is
talking about now said I mean chain
migration is really the problem are you
gonna commit to chain migration ending
and we have a past we've said that it
should be limited to immediate family we
should say we've always said it should
be a merit-based system of immigration
yeah I've always said that we need
border security including a wall and the
entry exit tracking system Eve Arif I
these are all things we've long
supported the debate is do you link it
the Democrats don't want to do you link
it to anything else
immigration selection is Trump's
election result is a mandate to change
this change this approach and really
focus as you said on the American worker
who's been hammered by lousy immigration
polymeric based immigration system which
by the way is also a reality in the 21st
century it's fundamentally different
than it was dat the Roy Moore issue he's
up in the polls he may very well win
this race what happens if he wins and it
comes to Washington the people of
Alabama made their own call it's not our
call it's their call are you in favor of
an ethics investigation that could
perhaps lead to 2/3 of the members
expelling infamous well first of all
there is an ethics investigation that's
the first thing I don't even know how
you initiate that well assuming that
that happens and people would obviously
make their decisions based on the facts
that emerge from it I think what's
complicating about it and I've said this
publicly before I don't to be frank I I
find the accusations against them to be
credible and I don't think anything he
has said or done in the last couple of
weeks has helped them in that regard
that said this information is before the
voters of Alabama and if they elect him
and then you as a Senate have ethics
hearings to remove him from office or
something like that it gets more
complicated that's a little bit more
difficult and because because voters
will have this information before I when
they vote for him if in fact he's
elected this issue of government
shutdown Chuck Schumer has said in the
past on 2013 no government shutdown for
policy that's just ridiculous
yeah do you think he would actually shut
the government down if he doesn't get
his dreamer I
I don't think I don't think it'll be
very popular I don't think that you can
you I don't think you can or should shut
the government of the United States down
over that issue I just don't think you
can or should I think it's I think there
will be a massive revolt even perhaps
within his own conference and finally
this house shush slush fund on the
victims of you know for a bunch of
things especially on the settlements is
there any fun like that in the Senate
that you're I don't know I'm not aware
of it there probably is I wouldn't never
used it obviously but I think that
should be made public so you're in favor
you'll say tonight that these people
should be unmasked we should know who
these people are in the house who
settled or the Senate if there's such a
fun absolutely we should know that it's
public money it's not their money one
thing is have you settled with your own
money but if it's taxpayer money
taxpayers deserve to know it's great to
have you on tonight thank you so much
for coming on
thanks for sure thanks for having me